i want us in this time of division and
and fragmentation and fracture to find
ways of coming together
in peace coming together with peace
that's why i'm chatting to candice owens
and chat to you i don't want to sit
around chatting people i agree with
i want to talk to people where there are
areas of concern and discontent
and and downright disagreement and find
ways that we can
harmonize stand-up comedian russell
brand was established in show business
in the early 2000s presenting on mtv
posting a spin-off of tv's big brother
and then he was blasted into movie
stardom in 2008
most notably with his beloved character
aldous snow in forgetting sarah marshall
who could be the queen of the groupies
queen
of the sorrow suckers sorrow suckers
sorrow suckers i i don't know why they
call them his sharp wit and magnetic
persona continued to propel him to world
fame with international comedy tours
and hollywood movies but then around
russell publicly decided to step back
from the limelight
he continued with his comedy but also
committed his career towards spiritual
and political activism
he released a revolution a book about
nonviolent social change
away from contemporary capitalism and
toward the common good
he also wrote recovery a bestseller
about navigating addiction as someone
who's been addicted to
sex heroin fame and everything that
comes with that line of work
he's made documentaries exploring drug
addiction too and he's campaigned for
change in the treatment of addiction
in his home country the uk after
capturing an audience with his celebrity
he dramatically refocused and now brings
his audience along with him
on his journey through his podcast under
the skin
it goes without saying that russell's in
my own life experiences are pretty
different but in this episode
we find some things we have in common we
dive into his beliefs and what he wants
to achieve through activism
our agreements and disagreements on
human nature how universalism plays out
in reality
and our experiences as fathers
[Music]
hey hey and welcome this is the ben
shapiro show sunday special this show is
sponsored by expressvpn don't like big
tech and the government spying on you
visit expressvpn.com
ben just a reminder we'll be doing some
bonus questions at the end with russell
the only way to get access to that part
of the conversation is to become
a member head on over to dailywire.com
become a member you will have access to
all of the full conversations with every
one
of our awesome guests russell thanks so
much for joining the show i'm so happy
to be with you mate
so you know i think for a lot of my
audience this is always uh
these are sorts of weird um
i would say groupings uh the the the
fact that you and i are sitting together
uh is strange to a lot of people who who
kind of may not know
your your spiritual and political side
who may only be familiar with your work
in hollywood and i think your journey
really is sort of a fascinating one so
if you don't mind i'd like to
have you go through that journey a
little bit because you know as you know
people sort of pop into public
consciousness for a moment in time and
then they sort of disappear and then
they pop again into public consciousness
and so i think a lot of my audience
isn't aware of like all the things that
you've been doing over the years and
sort of how you got from point a to
point b so why don't you start me
from the beginning how did you you know
make a name for yourself in the first
place
i'm a stand-up comedian primarily ben
that's my background
and while i was becoming stand-up
comedian i was also
studiously and diligently becoming a
drug addict
it took quite a lot of commitment it was
quite time consuming
and ultimately these two drives drive to
entertain and the drives to
numb pain competed in my
little biographical journey and the
stand-up comedy led to
like hosting stuff on mtv like mtv
vmas in your country and uh
also eventually doing movies and stuff i
trained as an actor but
and prior to sort of breaking out and
having one of those moments where i
would have breached public consciousness
particularly in your country and
i was married to like a famous famous
entertainer and singer over there casey
perry
and i very much was in the world of
celebrity and
sort of visible stardom at that point
um but the secondary journey or perhaps
more accurately an ulterior journey that
was sort of more important was that i
was dealing with sort of recovery and
waking up from kind of addiction and
attachment
around behavioral things as well as
obvious stuff like drugs from which i've
been clean for
a long time now and i feel like um
that it's very easy to form
appetite-based attachment to stuff like
fame and celebrity and money and power
and i would contest
that the sort of energy of addiction is
a key driver
in consumer-led cultures that the energy
of consumerism
is owes something to addiction and of
course i'm speaking
primarily from personal experience but
then who isn't and i reckon what
happened mate
is i got like world famous for a minute
and
some of that was fantastic other aspects
of it were challenging
and the sort of spiritual and domestic
aspects of my life have been sort of
subsequently
promoted to the forefront and now i live
what you might call
a comfortable but somewhat ordinary life
with
kids i've got beautiful children and
animals i'm married i live a kind of
domestic life and the sort of
the forefront of my consciousness and my
intentions ben
was an area which i think we have in
common are
my spirituality um like trying to become
a back person
trying to live in accordance with the
spiritual principles that have saved my
life and trying to think how i can be
beneficial while still hopefully on
occasion
sometimes inadvertently being
entertaining
so russell i want to talk to you about
your spirituality and your religion in a
second i think what's fascinating about
sort of your personal story is first of
all it's just the story of ecclesiastes
essentially i mean you
basically took the solomonic journey
through what if i had a thousand wives
and
a thousand horses and and then it seems
that you sort of came around to the view
that there was there's a certain
emptiness to that but
for for somebody like me so i grew up
religious right i grew up
from the time i was young teen like 11
12 13 years old
going to an orthodox synagogue very
steeped in the in these sort of
judeo-christian notions of personal
virtue
and and controlling appetites and all
that sort of stuff there there's always
a draw in in our culture
toward as you say the fulfillment of
those appetites and as somebody who
i mean you you really went whole hog on
a lot of this stuff maybe you can talk
about
you know when was it that you sort of
started to feel like maybe this isn't
the bl end all maybe maybe there's
something more than this
personally for me it took the
i it required that the encounters be
kind of lived through i understood
things
theoretically and spiritually long
before i was able to embody them and
live by them
i reckon it was it's quite hard to
monitor
how you feel if you're being
lauded and applauded if you're
successful financially
and being celebrated sometimes you can
lose
touch with what's actually happening to
you spiritually or you know if you're
not a religious person emotionally or
psychically
but i suppose in retrospect and i'm
certainly aware and at the time i had an
inkling that i was feeling a little
disconnected and because i'm so
privileged
to have this background in addiction and
more importantly in recovery
i began to recognize that any external
stimulant that begins to govern my
state my perception govern my moods
my the way i identify with myself could
potentially be categorized as
addiction if my life becomes about how
other people see me about what's written
about me
how uh how financially successful i am
then i'm kind of living in an external
object and
what i was able to well started to
awaken to because i wasn't happy that i
wasn't fulfilled
and i love your uh your classical
reference there ben
it's difficult though because things
that like the flesh is
satisfying drugs are fulfilling flowery
and praise
are enticing and distracting and it
still takes discipline in me
still now when i look at the world of
celebrity and
what i might classify as the world of
individualism egocentrism i still find
it kind of wow appealing and
i'm a professional person i have
intention and ambition i see the way
that you run a media organization and i
think well this is really sort of
successful
you know and i i still am stimulated and
attracted to
versions of success but the difference
is now i understand wholeheartedly and i
fully accept
that there is nothing external that can
ever make me feel resolved fulfilled or
complete that if i'm ever to feel
um connected valued and valuable
awake and aware that i have to live a
life of meaning and purpose now
you know you're speaking about your own
background that you had a set of
traditional
values that were accessible to you and
i'm sure i did in my own way i'm from
like a single parent family religion
wasn't sort of at the forefront
of our sort of cultural life i'm like
church of england that just means that's
the thing you get given you just issued
that on entry on arrival there's no like
study exams or outfits required you know
spirituality wasn't like something i was
particularly thinking about this
is in a way mate this this dovetails
with a kind of ideological tool that's
used often in recovery from addiction
the belief that most people are craving
spiritual fulfillment in some way
purpose
meaning a sense of community
togetherness
fairness justice that perhaps these
values are not entirely cultural but
somehow inherent
and those of us that grow up without
them might try to synthesize
those values by becoming successful or
by becoming a heroin addict
by you know becoming a devoted athlete
or by
hanging around strip clubs we're all
looking for meaning
purpose now and for me pleasure is a
kind of um
a palliative you know and what i really
need is purpose but the culture does not
promote these kind of messages the
culture
in my opinion promotes individualism
materialism
rationalism scientism if it can't be
measured then it isn't there
and for me i was a devotee of a
particular culture a culture that tells
you become successful
all the while i had these kind of
spiritual inclinations and yearnings but
i didn't know how to process them i
didn't
i wasn't really mentored until i got
clean from drugs and alcohol
and because those things are so
appealing and attractive you know
carnality
celebrity it took a it took a while it
took
being in it i'm very fortunate i feel
privileged to have had the experience
of the red carpets and the flash bulbs
and the adulation because now i
recognize
oh yeah i've been there still now though
ben i can see a picture of myself
in a situation of celebrity from 10
years ago
or whatever i'm thinking oh my god that
looks so appealing and cool
this that was must have meant something
but i remember
i remember that it is empty and for
people like most people like you know
when you hit those
famous surveys that are banded about
young people who want to be celebrities
they want to be famous
they don't even care what they're famous
for they just want to be famous you know
i i wonder how my life might have been
different if i'd have understood
that purpose and meaning can be
connected with
internally and all that you acquire
externally whilst it might provide
gratification pleasure and it is not
good fun being poor i can personally
vouch for that
these things are not the solution to
spiritual problems you know russell i
totally agree with so much of that i
want to get more into it in just one
second
first let's talk about your internet
privacy and security i'm worried about
it ben let me tell you the absolute
truth
i'm worried about my internet security
is there some system
some service i can use because i don't
know what to do i'm just i'm i'm out
here i'm panicking i'm frantic
i'm i'm so glad you asked russell it's
expressvpn have you ever read that fine
print that appears when you start
browsing
in incognito mode it says your activity
might actually still be visible to your
employer or your school or your isp
how can they even call that incognito to
really stop people from seeing the sites
you visit you need to do what i do and
use expressvpn
think about all the times you've used
wi-fi at a coffee shop a hotel even at
your parents house without expressvpn
every site you visit could be logged by
the admin of that network that's still
true even when you are in
incognito mode what's more your home
internet provider can also see and
record your browsing data and in the us
they are legally allowed to sell that
data to advertisers
expressvpn is the app that encrypts all
of your network data reroutes it through
a network of secure servers so your
private online activity stays just that
private expressvpn works on all your
devices it's super easy to use
the app literally has a button like one
you tap it to connect your browsing
activity is now secure
from prying eyes you don't want anybody
else accessing your internet activity
you do everything
on the internet why would you want
anyone else to have access to that stuff
stop letting strangers invade your
online privacy protect yourself
at expressvpn.com again use my link
expressvpn.com get three extra months
for
free that's expr essvpn.com ben to learn
more
so i totally agree with you i think that
when it comes to
what the media have have pushed upon us
and what what society
modern society pushes so much it's this
idea
that there are all of these sort of air
sats solutions for the hole in your
heart that is left when
there is the natural inclination for
spirituality and for spiritual
connection and
what i've said is that that the lack of
god has left a hole in our hearts and
we're trying to fill that with a wide
variety of things and and
for a lot of people that is stimulants
for a lot of people that is
that is sex for a lot of people that is
politics and and the substitution of
sort of political polarization
or tribal identification for you know
any sort of
of spiritual connection mission purpose
uh it's it's really easy to make that
mistake especially in a society that as
you say
tends to measure things on on a very
data-driven level that happiness equals
this number of dollars plus this number
of lovers plus this amount of
this number of houses plus this many
twitter followers and and the reality is
that none of that
is a substitute for the sort of meaning
and purpose that i mean pretty much
every philosopher since the dawn of time
has been searching for
yes and while we're in some ways
only qualified to speak about it
empirically from an individual
perspective it's clear that many of
these
uh values are culturally endorsed
to uh almost entirely uh to the point of
saturation
i feel like you know i've like i don't
get on tiktok too regular you know as a
user but i've looked at it and i felt
like my god the velocity
the potency now of that message the
power of it
i found it difficult enough not to look
at pornography when i was an adolescent
when it was analog rags
found in hedges and bushes now your
pocket is a portal to limitless
pixelated digital sex ghosts available
at a moment's notice
how are you gonna evolve a sophisticated
and loving and empathetic sexuality
when bombarded with that amount of
stimulation it's sort of an i suppose
you could
from a dietary perspective from a
technological and pornographic
perspective
um chart these markers but i wonder
where they are more insidiously present
in culture around ideas such as
economics i wonder where else
we're being hypnotized seduced and
guided by cultural messaging that is
not beneficial to individuals and is not
in tune with
even if you don't believe in creation or
divinity how we are evolved
to live so let's talk for a second about
your sort of view of spirituality so
there are a lot of folks out there who
consider themselves sort of spiritual
but not religious connected to something
deeper but
not sure exactly what or or not really
even directed toward exactly what so
how does your spirituality define
yourself you've talked about meaning and
purpose
what would you say your sort of meaning
is where do you find meaning
well i find the rubric through which my
spirituality is lived and understood
is unfortunately quite practical
in the i mean recovery from addiction
and what that gives you
is a set of principles and an ongoing
sort of almost cyclical system that you
can live within
the the first step in these 12 12 step
systems ben
is surrender i i don't know what to do
anymore
my life has got problems in it and i
don't know how to control it the second
step
is about having hope that change is
possible for you as an individual a lot
of people fall down there you know
whether it's in terms of chemical
dependency or
changing behavior or more broadly
because i can test these messages are
somewhat perennial and could be applied
anywhere in life a lot of people think
the world cannot change human beings are
essentially
you know defined by sort of cruelty
coldness selfishness or whatever so
you know these things are designed for
the individual but i think are
socially applicable so the second step
having admitted there's a problem the
second step is believing change is
possible
the third step is coming to believe that
a power greater than yourself
can restore the third power the third
step excuse me is
um made a decision to turn our will and
our life over to the care of god as we
understood god
now that's sort of completely open to
interpretation there are people in
12-step groups from
a variety of religious backgrounds and
no religious background
at all for me what it means is
the set of values and systems that i
come up with in my head
are if not arbitrary somewhat as a
result of my conditioning
and my impulses and instincts which i
could do with some guidance on i've
already admitted there's a problem
i believe it's possible to change now i
get ready to accept help
each one of these steps can be really
unpacked quite deeply and applied i
think
almost universally to matters of
discontent
loss loneliness excessive attachment
unwillingness to accept for uh that we
live a finite life you know i think
they're
really really powerful tools and what
it's done to what it did for me
i always had a sense of look i i always
embraced mystery
drug addicts usually do if you've taken
psychedelic drugs and had the kind of
experiences that they induce
if you feel the kind of despair and loss
and loneliness that a lot of addicts
feel and the kind of conditions that
becoming a drug addict introduce you to
the criminality and the kind of you know
sort of cliche desperation that one
might encounter
in a sense it opens you up to the
possibility of god because
nothing for me you know i know you're
like a
you know you're a religious man and also
know that you know theology and that you
know scripture
but suffering it like i'm not making
claims to job levels of suffering but to
be introduced to god
on that level of knowing i am weak on my
own i am
weak i need something powerful in my
life
me fueled just by my ego and my petty
trivial desires i will live a petty
trivial life i need something powerful
and now i don't know if that's
applicable to anybody i'm sure many of
your viewers are religious i'm sure many
of them are atheistic i'm sure
many of them are individualistic it's
pointless even really to speculate but
for me
personally i need to feel that there is
beauty that there is love that there is
a kind of glory
and i think whether we're talking about
like sort of the success of marvel
movies and the way they introduce
archetypes and grand themes or
the kind of tensions that we feel
politically sometimes or the
epidemic of mental health problems and
opioid addiction in your country
currently
this for me is demonstration of the the
yearning the need for real change
and in my humble opinion and god knows i
know your opinion differs for me
these problems cannot be resolved within
the limited framework of current
political discourse
we need to invite meaning and purpose
and if not more
directly god back into the conversation
of how we construct society and how we
organize systems of governance and uh
even exchange so i mean i i totally
agree with so much of that and when it
comes to the role of government i think
that's where we sort of disagree because
i think that a lot of this is to be done
on the social level and and i think that
also how we sort of orient ourselves
toward
the world around us is is a really
important thing and and so
one question that i would ask when you
talk about spirituality finding meaning
finding purpose if you go back to sort
of the classical philosophers if you go
back to
aristotle he talks a lot about teleology
he talks about telos the idea that
that using your reason uh you can
discover telos in the universe natural
law that governs the universe
uh and and what he really means by that
is that if there are certain things that
are designed to achieve certain purposes
then you'll live your happiest life if
you recognize what those are and then
you live
in consonance with that now that can
lead you to some pretty ugly places
depending on
on how rationalistic you get right i
mean aristotle
at the same time that he's promoting the
idea of freedom of rationality is at the
same time promoting the idea that there
are actual hierarchies of human beings
in which some people should be held to
slaves so it's easy to see how this sort
of logic can lead to the wrong places
on the other hand you know the the
attempt to sort of
disconnect the world from any sort of
purpose to disconnect the world from a
teleology
uh also leads to so it leads to the
nihilism and despair that we see so
how do you find the sort of middle
ground in as to what you think are the
rules for the road
what do you think the rules for the road
should be for an individual and what do
you think the rules for the road should
be
in terms of a society and then in terms
of government because i think those are
three separate categories and i think
that very often
our mushy sort of political thinking
conflates all three it's like what i
like for individuals is what i also want
a government to do or what i want
society to do is what i want the
government to do and i think it's pretty
important to sort of tease out
what we should expect from each one of
those sort of categories individuals
society and government in these three
areas mate the sort of rules for an
individual the rules for society and the
rules of a government
yes of course there are like at scale
many simplistic
ideologies begin to warp and break down
and look i'm aware of you and i know
that you're aware of me and we've had a
conversation before
you know and what i feel
is that i would anticipate perhaps
certainly from the comments i get
underneath my own youtube channel
is that a lot of people seem to think
like i may be like a communist or
something
and a communist of course infers a
highly empowered
centralized state and this is not what i
believe in at all
i'm i believe that all of us
are have a right like you know
constitutional thomas paine type
territory
all of us have a right to pursue
happiness and freedom and i don't think
that can be possible under certain
conditions i don't think it can be
impossible if there are if there is the
imposition of unconscious hierarchies i
don't think it can be possible if
there's too much centralized state power
intervening in the lives of
individuals and i don't think it can be
possible anymore
when that we are aware of the variety of
and diversity of ways that there are to
be human
it seems like even when you watch
something from history a hundred years
ago there was more tribalization there
was an acceptance of balkanization
separation and and i'm like talking
about times that were quite fraught with
war genocide and horror of course
but what we did not have then is this
kind of
uh in a cultural gl and in domed culture
where there is a kind of a presumed
set of morals ethics and norms that are
imposed over everybody
that people we're all trying to appeal
to a set of values
that often seem at odds with our
individual freedom
let me put it a little more positively i
feel that there's
so many different ways of being now that
we need to decentralize wherever
possible we need to accept that there
are people that have entirely different
sets of beliefs and values
from one another and just because
they're different it doesn't mean that
they're not right
and i would like you know i'm sure look
me and you could probably get into
arguments about gun control
about pro-life pro-choice about israel
palestine
i'm sure there's so many things that you
and i would argue about and frankly i'd
rather not have those arguments because
i think you're a
very very skilled rhetorician and i
think that when
one is very good at arguing sometimes
you can win arguments without
necessarily being right
and my feeling is that when we are so
different from one another we're gonna
what why are we trying to centralize why
are we trying to create these huge
dominions when
so many varied people are being
asked to liver homogenized normalized
centralized and ultimately as a result
of that oppressed lifestyle
as an individual i want to be who i am
i've always been sort of a kind of arch
individualist
just by default i want to live in
communities where people share my values
and are there through choice freely i
don't think that we as
essentially evolved advanced enlightened
potentially divine
primates can live in communities of
millions hundreds of thousands
i feel that we should live you know when
we spoke before ben
and you talked about how your orthodox
jewish community is established around a
synagogue around a central set of values
built around family and community and
shared beliefs
of all there's a lot in that there's a
lot in that
and i feel at heart communities
need a shared purpose you know i'm a big
fan of that sebastian younger book reads
the tribe where he talks about the sort
of the experience that service people
have when they come home the loss of
purpose the loss of meaning
because in in our crazy world being in
the military
in the in combat is a closer
approximation of how we evolved to live
than living in a bland
nihilistic urbanized empty hollowed-out
culturally vacuous consumerist culture
so you know like we are going to have
weird diverse
varied ways of living and i think that
in a sense i've long fought ben and i
would love your input on this
that we almost don't need i heard the
wonderful quote once um
the world doesn't need more people to
believe in god just
for those of us that do to start acting
like it
and i think that the world doesn't need
new ideas democracy
constitutional rights just these
existing ideas to be lived out
correctly so individuals and freedoms
and societies have a degree
of uh autonomy where possible
and an acceptance that people are
different people have different values
why are we
creating all these hot button points to
quarrel and argue over
well if in my opinion at least the the
dominant problem remains the same that
there's a small strata
of society individuals and institutions
that have uh largesse over the way that
society is organized and most people are
quarreling over crumbs so i again i i
feel that we're agreeing a lot here
because
the the attempt to sort of homogenize
society and then demand that everybody
lives the same way
i think is really destructive and you
can see it in the united states and this
is one of the reasons why i fear the
idea of a centralized power particularly
in government because government
in my view is essentially a gigantic gun
and basically whoever controls the gun
now controls how everybody else lives
and i'd prefer that the gun basically uh
be a very very
tiny peashooter that is directed in very
specific
directions at people who are attempting
to do active harm to other people
otherwise i don't want that gun to
really be there because i don't want
that gun pointed at me and i don't feel
i should be pointing the gun
at anybody else you know localism and
communitarianism but
in local communities as opposed to
trying to broaden that out universal
in a universalistic fashion uh i think
that that is
one of the answers is the sort of
decentralization that we're that we're
talking about and i think that
you and i agree very much on that and
and honestly i'm happy to keep the
conversation
at the level that we're that we're going
here and the reason for that is because
i've always suggested that political
conversations usually are taking
place on sort of the top of the iceberg
right so if we're if we're talking about
gun control
there are a bunch of values that are way
below gun control that people are
actually arguing about when they're
arguing about gun control and those
arguments are things about
the nature of human beings are human
beings naturally sort of dangerous to
one another that requires us to have
guns in self-defense or
do human beings have an individual right
to keep and bear arms and to to what
extent
do those rights conflict if those rights
now extend to more and more dangerous
weaponry right
those those are underlying values
conversations i think the more
interesting conversations are the ones
that go directly to the underlying
values rather than the ones that take
place
on the top of the iceberg and so in a
second i want to ask you about some of
those underlying values particularly
with regard to human nature because
i totally agree with you that that human
beings are living in a wide variety of
ways now i think that
there is a human tendency which is to
see everybody else as a threat to you
and that drives people to want to
control everybody else's way of life so
as to prevent
those people from threatening them and
so well
i'm a big fan of heterogeneous living
and different communities living as
there have to be certain baseline
agreements about things
like human rights or individual rights
only ask you about that in just
one second first it is time for you to
buy life insurance
i'm panicking i'm panicking about my
life what happens if i die what's down
to my kids
i mean you're a responsible person
russell and that is why i'm sure you
already have life insurance to protect
your children actually no tell me what
sort of choices should i be making
it is time for you to buy life insurance
if you're a serious human being you need
to make sure
that you know if your plots your family
is taken care of and this month there's
a lot going on you've got father's day
flag day national yo-yo day thankfully
policy genius is going to make it easy
to cross life insurance
off that list if somebody relies on your
financial support whether it's a child
an aging parent even a business partner
you need
life insurance policy genius makes it
easy to compare quotes from over a dozen
top insurers
all in one place why compare well you
could save 50 or more on life insurance
policies by comparing quotes
with policy genius you could save 1300
bucks or more per year on life insurance
by using policy genius to compare
policies the licensed experts at policy
genius work for you they don't work for
the insurance companies so you
can trust them to help you navigate
every single step of the shopping and
buying process
that kind of service has earned policy
genius an excellent rating on trustpilot
getting started
super simple first head to
policygenius.com in minutes you can work
out how much life insurance coverage you
need
and compare personalized quotes to find
your best price when you're ready to
apply the policy genius team will handle
the paperwork and the scheduling
for free policy genius never sells your
information to other companies
policy genius doesn't add on extra fees
head on over to policygenius.com get
started right now
policy genius when it comes to insurance
it's nice to get it right
alrighty so let's talk about uh you know
a couple of things that you mentioned we
talked about
sort of the the belief in in human
potential and the ability to to live
lives of meaning
and purpose and the the problems with
great institutional power
and i think that there's there are
almost two separate topics and i'd like
to dive into them one at a time
so when it comes to human beings one of
the sort of classical traditions and
this is true in judeo-christian
tradition it's also true in sort of
ancient greek philosophy
and it's true for most of western
history and even in islam in the islamic
world
uh there's this belief that there is
such a thing as an innate human nature
and that you run up against
challenges in innate human nature and
that what civilization is really about
whatever your form of civilization is is
tailoring
yourself to the demands of human nature
and the society
around you and i think that is a very
different view of what identity
was than what identity has now become
there's a view that i think is now very
prevalent
that human beings are entirely
self-created that we're completely
malleable we can be whatever we want to
be
and that what we are searching for is
not a way of living in the world
but instead in inner authenticity and
then we demand that everybody around us
sort of
mirror our authentic view of ourselves
and to me that that is dangerous and
prevents us from living in a society
because in order for us to actually
share a society even in a small
community we have to understand the
rules of the road
and that there are limits to what i can
demand of you so i want to know from
from you
how do you see human nature i i sort of
as a religious person have the
the both optimistic and pessimistic view
of human nature that human beings as
james madison put it in in the
federalist papers are capable of being
both angels and devils which is why they
require some
societies to to shape and mold them and
then there's the sort of
you know russoian view that human beings
are naturally good and if you just leave
them all and they'll be fine
what is your view on that i suppose my
from my personal experience and from my
own reading i would
have to if not conclude currently
reside in a place where i see an
amalgamation of these ideas
there is no question when you know you
and i in our own ways are
both cultural commentators and the
reason we're commentating on culture is
because we're recognizing that culture
has a power to shape and
form influence and mold behavior if it
has that power
then likely therefore we are
to a degree a product of this cultural
um sculpting or manipulation let's call
it
but i also believe and this i suppose
comes
from a a somewhat mystical and
perhaps even esoteric perspective
that there is an innate
awareness within us i believe
that there is uh to use a word you used
earlier
a telos that in the same way we might
appreciate
that a seed planted and correctly
nurtured will find its formation and
fulfillment as a particular kind of
plant or tree and acorn will
given the correct conditions become an
oak tree that suggests that in
its nature there are some inherent
values that are
being expressed once human beings are
like highly socialized apes there are so
many ways of expressing
who we are certain values are promoted
necessarily
certain uh traits instincts are denied
controlled
inhibited prohibited in some cases and
that would seem
to be a prerequisite of order and ben i
would refer to an earlier part of our
conversation that already we're in
territory where no one can claim
objectivity
that no one can claim to have a a unique
insight and and what are all of us as
religious people doing other than saying
no i believe i'm interpreting
a divine sublime and absolute will and
and people are doing that now culturally
that you know from an academic or a
scientific perspective this is reality
from a religious perspective no this is
reality my feeling is that
well i feel that this is the reality
these are my values this is how i would
like to live i very strongly one thing i
believe then most strongly is that
my spiritual values are for me they are
to make me
a better person in the world so that i
am non-judgmental so i am compassionate
so i am
kind so i am understanding so that i
don't think that my views my values my
will are the most important thing in the
world because i recognize in myself
that there are states when that is how i
feel that there are states
in me where all i care about is what i
want and what i believe
and i require a degree of
openness of fluidity of the ability to
learn alter change
evolve i recognize that there are people
that have a
wholly different perspective on the role
of genetics and biology and identity i
reckon i recognize that again to your
point earlier about the
underlying values as opposed to the tip
of the iceberg
what i try to do when i'm in a position
of doubt is is i ask
again or investigate again what do i
mean by god
what do i mean by love and if i can
somehow rationalize something as
potentially
nebulous and diffuse as love what i mean
is a sense of union
of oneness whether i love a football
team or a country or a pair of shoes or
my partner or my kids there's a sense
that we are somehow whole and one
and part of my spiritual journey is to
find a perspective
where i feel this oneness this
fraternity brotherhood
sisterhood with as many people
potentially with all people though even
when i disagree with them i
recognize that there is a oneness that
there is a shared
sense of community and the more we
understand about the universe and dark
matter and potential other life forms
the more it seems preposterous for me to
augment fortify and hunker down into
positions
of uh oppositionism and uh contrarianism
and conflict so for me i recognize there
are so many things about me that seem
peculiar and unique i recognize that
there are things about me that seem
universal when it comes to power and the
issuing of edicts
what i most strongly believe in is as
you have tagged earlier localism and
community
i want to live around people that want
to live the way that i want to live
and i my prayer is that there are a set
of universal principles
that wherever you fall on these various
spectra
of identification whether these are sort
of traditional
perhaps conventional ideas or very
modern ideas
if we have recourse to what i call
sesame street ethics kindness compassion
tolerance then
it's not going to bother me it's not
going to bother me because
you okay yeah you can express yourself
and be yourself however you want to be
and
when we you and i are now tagging terms
like universal
surely what we mean by that is don't
harm other people
don't take other people's stuff let
people
live how they want to live and it's very
difficult because
because there are certain platform
structures and institutions that have
been
set up in particular ways as you know
our mutual
friend acquaintance jp would say you
know what a culture does
is creates biases for its dominant or
majority
population that's what it's supposed to
do what else
can it do this is and this is where we
get to the question that i was asking
about what do you think the rules of the
road are for society so i agree with you
that on a general individualistic level
that you know the the sort of basic
rules for the road treat other people
with decency
uh be nice to other people those go a
long way
i'm not sure that they go all the way
because you do eventually run into areas
where you are demanding from somebody
else that your version of niceness is
actually
a demand on them and this happens all
the time in societies and that brings
you to the question
of what are the rules of the road for
society a sort of bland universalism
uh can can sometimes actually degrade
into
atomistic living if if all you demand of
everybody is
be nice to one another and then
everybody has a subjective definition of
what niceness is right and this isn't me
just being lawyerly
some people's version of niceness
involves i have to
you know for example violate my own
religious scruples in order to quote
unquote be nice
uh and maybe my version of niceness is
that you have to leave me alone to
perform my religious scruples and this
bothers you in some way
what are the rules for a road when these
when these sort of values come into
conflict with one another
is the question for for how societies
live together because universalism is
is really nice on sort of a sort of a
vague level but
as we see in western societies unless
there are some
you know even more deeply rooted values
and in terms of what societies are meant
to do
what sort of values do we wish to
promote to our kids then
it's pretty easy for all of this to fall
apart on contact with reality and other
human beings
well what i feel ben and this might
drive you and i
potentially out of an income is that
somewhere between at the atomization and
the universalism
are some intermediary gradients of scale
and my feeling is is if there are a set
of cultural values that are
odds with my own then if they can
be run cohesively and in a contained
manner without
influencing the set of values that i
hold
then it's none of my business it's none
of my business
even if i disagree with it as i sort of
indicate to you
things that happen in my own life in my
own household that i don't agree with
but i recognize and
acknowledge and respect the autonomy of
for example
my wife like take something relatively
prosaic although not in the
the communities that um deify these
ideas i'm vegan
i'm vegan because i've always been
vegetarian i got pressured into veganism
i love animals but being like you know i
love them my dog's right here now
okay fair enough i'll be vegan i'm vegan
now leave me alone i've become vegan
but i'm not but my wife is not a vegan
like now like someone said to me you
should make your wife a vegan
oh well that's just is this a feminist
counter argument you might want to bring
to making my wife a vegan you know so i
like i'm not trying to impose
my veganism like my kids are vegetarian
i tell them like hey look some people
they eat animals and sometimes my kids
they say stuff you know you're a father
you hear the stuff that comes out of
these people the borderline barbarians
they are sometimes these little human
beings i'm raising maybe that's just my
kid
i'll kill i'd like to kill the okay okay
okay you know for me i'm
with them now we're born we die some
people don't believe in god i do believe
in god some people eat animals i don't
believe in animals some people believe
this i believe this i can only give you
my set of values i've been charged with
the job of
preparing you parenthesis i'm gonna
provide brackets around you i'm gonna
let you be who you
are and i'm gonna offer you the best
i've got knowing i'm wounded
knowing i'm flawed knowing that i don't
actually really know either
i'm open to learn you know i learn from
all the time they
shout stuff at me they startle and shock
me with their rawness and their beauty
sometimes i think they're closer to the
source than i am
maybe like maybe perhaps life is a
journey moving away from this divine
light
rather than towards it but ben to this
point of conflict you know we know where
it leads
it leads to war it leads the cultural
war it leads to military war when
cultures can't agree on a set of values
and this is again when i'm talking about
state centralization
you know this is something that may
somewhat wrangle with the
patriotism that i assume is is somewhat
embedded in your voting strong
right hey baby give me that ben
give me that ben give me that germanic
philosophical term
is the um is that what
if the united kingdom is not of service
to them
a significant number of people in the
united kingdom what is united kingdom
who benefits who is benefited if the
united states
is no longer beneficial to a significant
why have
the united states why not have true
confederacy why not have true autonomy
why not have true devolution devolve
power wherever possible
now what happens sovereignty whenever
you bring up these things sovereignty
muscles in its old argument
you need us to protect you if you don't
have us
then the terrorists are coming then the
darkness is coming i'm not suggesting
that we don't have you you
municipality into communication rail
systems and all the many other things i
simply don't have time to reflect on
because they don't have enough glitter
on them
but what i would say is where possible
let people run their own lives you know
it's more and more ben
i find myself agreeing with
libertarianism and
agreeing with anarcho-syndicalism yes
the rights of the individual but
some we have responsibility for one
another you know like you're a religious
man
we are god's children we are here to
love one another and once that
gets politicized into welfare i've heard
your discourse around subjects around
sort of
welfare and victim mentality and stuff
like that and this is probably the area
where i would
you know seem compared at least to you
mate
more kind of oh god i've got to help
people but for me i don't want to be no
bleeding heart liberal for me like there
is a sort of a great power
in believing in god like a might a glory
we can change the world we can create a
better world
it doesn't have to be like this even in
your constitution it said you know
you're gonna have to update this because
people are
drifting all sorts of bad habits you
know i mean i'm paraphrasing
but but like you know this is the kind
of responsibility we have as individuals
and i think we should undertake it then
in good faith in good faith to one
another like okay you're from a
different world to me you've got loads
of different beliefs to me
but i'm not gonna look to make you my
enemy
i'm gonna enjoy and love the things
about you
that i agree with and see where we can
find ways
to live harmoniously
yeah so russell i think that this is
where to me the the
great greece in the wheel that allows
what you're talking about to happen is a
certain set of societal rules that are
more informal than formal
and imposed from the top and in just one
second i want to ask you
about sort of where the conflict occurs
and how we create the societal greece
that allows us to live with each other
while disagreeing with each other about
a wide variety of things
first let's talk about your sleep
quality i'm exhausted
i'm not getting any sleep ben i'm wide
awake all night
the shouting helix sleep my friend when
i am traveling
one of the big problems for me is i
can't sleep as well as i do in my own
bed why well because when i am home
i am on a mattress made just for me
helix sleep
they've got a quiz it takes just two
minutes to complete it matches your body
type and sleep preferences
to the perfect mattress for you why
would you buy a mattress made for
someone else
with helix you're getting a mattress you
know will be perfect for the way you
sleep
everybody's unique helix knows that they
have several different mattress models
to choose from they've got soft
medium firm mattresses mattresses great
for cooling you down if you sleep hot
even a helix plus mattress for plus size
folks it's been awesome getting unboxing
videos from so many of you who also
found the helix mattress of your dreams
so
if you are looking for a mattress take
the quiz order the mattress that you're
matched to the mattress comes right to
your doorship for free you don't ever
need to go to a mattress store again
helix is awesome you don't need to take
my word for it helix is awarded the
number one best overall mattress pick of
2020 by both gq and wired magazine
head on over to helixsleep.com ben take
their two minute sleep quiz they will
match you to a customized mattress that
will give you
the best sleep of your life they have a
10 year warranty you get to try it out
for 100 nights risk free
they'll even pick it up for you if you
don't love it but you will and i love my
helix sleep mattress it is the only
thing that connects me to reality since
the only thing allowing me to sleep is
my helix sleep mattress helix is
offering up to 200 bucks off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners
at helixsleep.com go check them out
both you and i have these sort of
libertarianish tendencies when it comes
to
allowing people to live sort of how they
want so long as it doesn't bother me
there are sort of two areas where
where i think this this philosophy tends
to come into conflict with the real
world one is
we've broadened the definition of harm
pretty dramatically so there was the
jon stewart mill harm principle that i
get to wave my fist around until it hits
you in the face at which point i've
harmed you
and now we've broadened out harm to
include things like emotional harm or
indirect harm
and this leads to you know more claims
of me against you right now i get to
make claims on you because
maybe you're threatening my emotional
state maybe you're refusing to accept my
authenticity
maybe my belief is that economics for
whatever reason
is i think falsely but you believe it's
a zero-sum game and so if i'm making
money it's because i'm somehow taking
money
away from you so there's the broadening
of harm as a definitional principle
and then there's also the the problem
that you were alluding to earlier which
is that
you have a couple of kids i have three
kids and as you say children are little
barbarians right children
are are innocent and they are wonderful
and they are cute
and they are horrible little people
right all they do all day long
is is do extraordinarily selfish things
punctuated by some of the cutest stuff
that you've ever seen in your life like
if you met a 40 year old who acted like
a four-year-old
they would be on death row right if
four-year-olds had the capacity to
actively wield weapons
half the they'd be like nanos half the
world's population would be gone right
and i speak as the father of a
seven-year-old a five-year-old and a
one-year-old
i mean again they're wonderful i love
them but the purpose of civilization the
purpose of parenting
is in fact to provide guidance and so
it's it's easy to be sort of
you know culturally libertarian-ish and
and allow for a lot of subjectivity and
how people live their lives when you
raise your own child obviously you want
to set boundaries for that
and also we have to i think define what
harm means
pretty narrowly in order to allow for
people to live
their own lives and where i see us going
societally
is in almost precisely the opposite
direction we are we're defining harm
extremely broadly to the point where
mere offense is now considered harm
dictating that i'm going to go get the
government or i'm going to use societal
pressure in order to
actively destroy you your career your
family
and at the same time dictating to people
that
actively parenting your kids societal
institutions societal values
civilizational values that i use to
guide my children
are in fact a form of bad indoctrination
that only we should be able to educate
your kids
in the way that we see fit so how do you
kind of square the circle in terms of
allowing people to live their own lives
for me it's you know define harm very
narrowly
and allow a pretty broad parental remit
when it comes to
how you bring up your children so long
as again you are not
indoctrinating them in in true violent
harm uh or in
in you know situations in which they are
likely to be you know harming themselves
uh because presumably adults should know
more than kids and you should already
know the rules of the road right i mean
i'm sure that
you're teaching your daughters not to do
a lot of the things that you did when
you were young that's what means being
an adult right the difference between
being an adolescent and being an adult
i completely agree with the obligations
of a parent i feel perhaps some of these
to parrot a point you made earlier that
sometimes these ideas that work within
the institution of the family
are mapped onto a culture and a society
and what better
analogy could there be for the notion of
patriarchy other than those in power are
kind of like a benevolent
disciplining but ultimately loving
father an idea that is
clearly vocally being challenged and
rejected
i know that there are there are
certainly loads of things ben that you
could say to me that would really hurt
me
like and i would feel that we have a
kind of contract
and perhaps there are things i could say
that would hurt you although you seem
kind of like a robust guy i've got to
say and you'd have to be to do what you
do
and and i respect you for that um but i
would
if i thought i'd said something that
hurt you i would not like it
i would not like it and i apply that to
anybody i if i don't want people to be
in pain i don't want people to suffer
and who am i to impose a definition
of harm upon them again i return to this
point of a centralized
idea of what america or a nation or even
a set of ideals
are how can we all be expected to harbor
one another's diverse
sets of ideals why should we live on
in this frontier of ongoing conflict
when we could just accept
that you know accept what seems to us
personally unacceptable except for where
it's bloody obvious that you don't kill
harm impose take away people's rights to
consent all of these kind of you know
kind of obvious ethics and values there
is so much
emergent conflict and sometimes i think
it's a confection sometimes i think
these culture wars
are what i want to say inflated
promoted escalated to prevent us from
talking about what you and i are
blessedly discussing today underlying
values
so with harm i recognize there are some
things you know i'm a comedian so when
i'm in that space
in my head you know and i i'm not there
particularly today except for when you
do the ad reads then i see a real
opportunity for humor ben real
opportunity and i want to get in there
with you
you know but i'm in a sort of an open
space where i feel like
what i want to do is understand you and
be giving
giving to you and generous to you even
though as we have both listed and are
both surely
aware there are loads of the stuff that
i'm we would disagree on and that we
would be able to
fill an hour on every single one of
those subjects if we so chose to
but you know when i hear you talk about
your children or your religion or your
wife
i feel like oh yeah you're just
basically the same as me in limitless
space you're
gonna die like i'm gonna die why are we
gonna quarrel about the stuff we don't
agree
on you know so for me this idea of harm
yeah i can see how
some people come from communities either
historically as a result of their
cultural
uh ethnic or racial identity are
traumatized for me that seems like a
very very real thing i've spent
some time studying it perhaps not as
much as you but the idea of inherited
pain and trauma
emotionally and mentally spiritually
physically and
obviously economically seems like a very
real thing in forms of individual
identitarian matters i i
feel that the subjective experience for
all of us is by
its nature a mystery and
you know in areas of complexity and con
confusion
my personal choice would be to when the
lord allows it
to er on the side of okay i don't want
to harm anybody i
i feel like if i live the rest of my
life without harming another person
without another person walking away from
an interaction with me feeling that they
feel cheapened or not heard or not who
they are
then i feel like i'm i have a connection
to god
so i've got everything i need i'm not
looking for it out there no more
and i don't want to be pulled back out
there i want us in this time of division
and fragmentation and fracture to find
ways of coming together in peace coming
together with peace that's why
i'm chatting to candice owens and chat
to you i don't want to sit around
chatting people i agree with
i want to talk to people where there are
areas of concern and discontent and
and downright disagreement and find ways
that we can
harmonize and live together because i'm
not coming to live in your house with
you i'm not going to start going in why
don't you do this with your kids
and presumably you're not going to do
the same with me so it's hypothetical
it's hypothetical and for the people
that these subjects are real the people
that feel
challenged about the way they are the
way that they identify
often it's i must admit i cannot
comprehend it or understand it but
as best i can that's part of what they
are saying they are saying you don't
understand you'd understand
okay that's okay i want people to be
happy i don't want to hurt anyone
so when i find myself in these areas of
complexity i think where in me can i
find love where in me can i find love
and where is the real power here ben
this is what i return to and i know this
sort of seems like an evolved sort of
post-modern sort of marxist idea
but but i feel that the obligation lies
with where the power is if you are
if when we're talking about powerful
corporations powerful media businesses
powerful institutions
well this is the issue you can't get
anything like you know if you're
fiddling around with all these little
pipsqueaks
quarreling about stuff down there the
real issue is
who gets to dom who gets to decide on
the geopolitical
or national political level the kind of
lives that we are going to live the kind
of resources we're going to have access
to and not have access to
and are those systems in themselves
moribund broken corrupt ridiculous in
you
in my opinion in your country and mine
you know when i hear you
criticize power i agree with you
sometimes when i hear you criticize what
in my view are
people that are less powerful this is
where i find myself not in alignment
with your perspective i
i say this with respect no this is a
really important idea and i want to get
into it in in just one second about you
know how we hold
people accountable is that a power game
or is that really a principle game
because i do think that that is a really
deep sort of philosophical divide that's
happening right now
first let's talk about how you can make
your employees
happier how you can find better
employees for your company oh my god i
actually do need to know that
like if your business is growing you
need a fast easy way to fill open
positions and find the best people
if you're a business owner hiring you
probably face a lot of challenges when
it comes to finding the right person for
your role right now which is why hiring
can often feel like trying to find a
needle in a haystack
so you could post your job to some job
board then all you can do is hope the
right person comes along that's why you
should try ziprecruiter for free
at ziprecruiter.com ben guest because i
have a guest when you post a job on zip
recruiter it gets
sent out to over 100 top job sites with
one click then
zip recruiters matching technology finds
people with the right skills and
experience for your job
and actively invites them to apply in
fact zip recruiter is so effective that
four out of five employers who post on
zip recruiter get a quality candidate
within the very first day
it's no wonder over 2.3 million
businesses have come to zip recruiter
for their hiring needs
it can be really difficult to find the
right person when you are searching
thousands of resumes but this is why zip
recruiter is so valuable
while other companies overwhelm you with
way too many options ziprecruit will
find you what you're looking for
that needle in the haystack and right
now you can try ziprecruiter for free
at this web address ziprecruiter.com ben
guest once again
remember to go to this unique and
magical place ziprecruiter.com
b-e-n-g-u-e-s-t zip recruiter is indeed
the smartest way to hire
alrighty so let's talk for a second
about sort of this this
idea that i think has has crept into the
public discourse recently
uh that the the chief goal of of
politics and political discussion
and maybe even philosophic discussion is
connected with power so
this whole conversation we've been
talking mainly on the individual level
and it's a thing where i think we find
tremendous agreement because
a lot of the principles that you
personally hold about you know personal
responsibility taking responsibility for
your own life and
and recognizing that you have agency in
your own life and at the same time
acknowledging that you may not have
all of the moral answers within yourself
but you may have to look to external
sources
for all of that i think there we share a
broad base of agreement
i tend to treat the the question of
morality as an individual one and so for
me it's much less a question
of power dynamics than it is a question
of whether somebody is acting immorally
or not
so to take an example there's a broad
discussion obviously happening in the
united states that's now extended over
to the uk
about the definition the very definition
of racism now it used to be that the
definition of racism was fairly well
understood by everybody it was the
the at least back in the 1950s and 60s
because we were seeing it practiced on a
daily level
right and legal legally encoded in law
in many places in the united states
it was a belief in the inferiority
inferiority or superiority
of a particular group of people based on
race right that was the definition of
racism
now the definition of racism has been
shifted and there's this different
conversation taking place
in which the notion is that it's not
just that sentiment
it is systems of power in general that
end with
unequal outcome must therefore be racist
or
alternatively that only people with
power can be racist so if you're
powerless
and you are bigoted against somebody
else you might be bigoted but you're
really not racist because real racism
and the real challenge of racism isn't
a challenge inside the human heart that
we all have to fight it's not the sort
of individual fight that you have in
order to live a more
virtuous and fulfilled life or the same
fight that i have really it's a question
of power dynamics
and this is where i start to get very
skeptical of of
some of the definitional issues here
because to me if morality
is now disconnected from individual
action
or or even solving individual problems
and it now moves up to the level of
only people with power are a problem in
terms of how they act morally or
all inequalities of of outcome a result
of an imbalance of power at the top
uh i don't think that the logic holds
nor do i actually think that the logic
is particularly moral
i think that power can appear
in many forms
i was born without much access to
financial
resources i.e i grew up in an ordinary
single parent family me and my mother
there's
no real resources there's a a a degree
of
welfare now
i however though was born with i
fortunately can string a sentence
together i can tell a joke under
pressure
i can you know i have a skill set that
the society i was born into values and
through
you know opportunity hard work whether
but even the hard work
i was born with this because i believe
in god i didn't give myself the ability
to work hard
i didn't give myself the ability to keep
doing stand-up comedy for
nothing above pubs year after year with
people literally throwing objects at me
and keep going and keep going i like
even though that was a
tough old task i kept going at it but i
can't take personal credit for that
i was seemingly born with the ability or
even if it was
culturally acquired i didn't give myself
the culture either so power i think
you know personal power cultural power
is a like a it's uh there are
various ways of approaching and
categorizing
something as ubiquitous and as difficult
to
pin down as the ability to get stuff
done if you want it or prevent things
happening
if you don't want it now like when that
starts to be
like laying out upon a culture ben i
feel
that we would have to acknowledge
history we would have to acknowledge the
history of your country of my country
let's take mine because it's not so
incendiary and i know people hear my
accent i think this guy is going to tax
me without representation
we're going to smash him up what's he
going to do next we'll tip his tea
into the boston sea damn it i i i think
that they say the uk
our wealth was largely accumulated by
legitimized piracy
under the uh uh livery and paraphernalia
of royalty and monarchy
in fact the more you dress something up
in gold and urban robes are more likely
that what's taking place is a crime
i feel like you know to somewhat con
countenance one of the things that you
mentioned earlier that often where you
find a huge amount of resources
there is a deficit elsewhere just due to
the finite nature of resources
that if in order to produce the
magnificent technology through which
we're communicating now
it is necessary that elsewhere on the
planet people are working
in conditions and for wages that are
sub-optimal
and i know like that many people will
make an argument of general progression
and the average person this and a dollar
a day and the average lifespan
and for me these are very sort of
complex arguments that don't take into
account industrialization and the effect
that that had on mortality and
many many many things i don't think that
we should be looking for ways to
differentiate ourselves from one another
and condemn one another i am
i i have no choice because of my own
spiritual values if people feel that
they
are persecuted and it's in a manner that
i can't
claim to understand because of the the
distinctions in my personal experience
then i i would rather choose the root of
compassion than condemnation
every time when you're talking about
vast subjects like race in america with
this very particular history
you know you and i have discussed this
elsewhere that just because it's
inc seemingly inconceivable that a debt
of that nature could ever be
repaid due to the complexity the number
of institutions corporations nations
individuals
potentially involved that for me that
does not foreclose the idea
of uh of reparations and while we're
using a word like foreclosed what the
hell went on in 2008 you know where
we're
regardless of race ordinary people uh
poor people in the main because who
suffers always
the poor that were ripped off skanked by
people who will
never it seems face the consequences of
their reckless actions exploitation is
happening
it seems on a large scale to have a
hierarchical society it seems you gotta
have a bunch of
schmoes near the bottom that you're
going to exploit and the more they're
fighting one another
on account of the books they read when
they try to
try to encounter the unknowable or the
way they feel about themselves and their
identity or their
sexuality if we can spend all our time
squabbling about that there's gonna be
no reorganization and
how i would take this to you bet is like
i feel like like that you have
power i know i don't mean this within
the terms of
uh perhaps how the conversation is
played out the power of your personality
your ability your willingness your
determination your certainty
and for me and i don't know you know
obviously you're a religious man and you
understand your religion deeply but for
me
the point of my religion is that one
make me about cope in this world knowing
i'm gonna die and everyone i love is
gonna die and that there is injustice
and there is unfairness
and two i want to be good i want to make
sure that i realize myself and i realize
myself as a loving and kind man and i
do well by people this is the function
of my spiritual life
one to give me a real experience of a
reality that's not just some cultural
concoction some
confection of balderdash and inherited
nonsense designed primarily to atomize
me off into a consumer to
make me a willing stooge in somebody
else's game
to set as happy to settle for the
trickle-down
no for me god is about i want to be
embrace reality and
i want to be able to actualize my fervid
sense
that we can create new and better worlds
for our imagination
but we don't need to confine ourselves
to this is the left this is the right
it's basically the same
that let's squabble within this tiny
window of issues let's
look at the underlying values let's
accept that it's highly like this
you know for a generation at least
probably more there's going to be
people polarized and apart can we come
to some solution
and a reason and i think sometimes the
reason it's so hard to find a solution
is that
the people in positions of true power
and authority
don't want there to be one they're
perfectly content even if it's not
you know dracula castle cabal shadowy
evil way
i i think they're perfectly happy for
people to be squabbling about
small change while the big money flies
upstream
so you know for me on these matters like
you know i can see a real historical
argument for example
for reparations i recognize that i can't
understand the experience of a
female non-white person and you know let
alone some kid in the congo get
dragging copper out of soil so my phone
will work you know we're all i'm i'm
embedded in this i'm involved in this
i'm
and so for me i don't i think it's just
you know to use the phrase i hear you
use a lot i think it's straw man for me
to be hitting on them i like even though
there's a lot of that and a lot of
badges and a lot of stuff going on for
me the
real deal is how can i be beautiful how
can we challenge real power and i don't
want to be
i don't want to be distracted i want to
ask you
about a couple of things that we've
touched on here one is sort of the
definition of compassion that we're
using because i feel like
everybody would love to be compassionate
and should want to be compassionate but
compassion it sort of materializes in a
couple of different ways
to me the most compassionate thing that
hearing your personal story that anybody
ever did for you is is providing the
framework for you to
move away from drug addiction right and
and give you back your own sense of
agency over your own life that was the
most compassionate thing
that ever happened to you presumably
somebody directed you into that or
helped you into that you had a group of
people who are supportive of you
during that helping people regain their
own agency
in jewish tradition and in most
judeo-christian tradition is
is helping people achieve agencies so
they can make their own decisions and so
that they can
and so that they are not deprived of
agency or treated as sort of
as in a sort of childish fashion uh
you know patriarchally as you suggest
but instead are given agency over their
own lives and i feel like a lot of the
discussions about compassion tend to
devolve into by compassion i mean
big people with big checks should sign
cash over to other people
as opposed to well maybe we need to
actually look at the incentive
structures look at human nature and
determine
what incentive structures in society
allow for people to
realize their own agency and make
decisions on their own that lead to them
feeling more free and feeling more more
purposeful
and and feeling a more meaningful life
so that that's question number one on
compassion and the second one is gonna
i want to get to is going to be about
the problem of subjectivism so a couple
of times you've talked about
sort of atomization of society and
respect for other individuals and how
they live their own lives
and i'm fully on board with that up
until the point where again
the fist meets my face because if
somebody is claiming that i have harmed
them
and i have not actually harmed them
they're making a claim upon me
and so i'm now going to have to
adjudicate whether i believe that that
claim is justified or not there's a big
difference i mean i have kids they fight
each other all the time
there is in fact a difference between if
my my daughter is lying about my son
hitting her and whether my daughter is
not lying about my son hitting her
or if they just have a difference of
perspective on how the hitting took
place
and who is right and who is wrong these
questions actually do matter and i'm not
sure we can just throw our hands up in
the air and say well nobody can
understand one another so everybody's
right
i agree that whilst genetically
it is clear there is apparently
infinite variety limitless individuality
it seems also to be true that we have
hearts lungs
generally speaking sensory organs and
within a
a broadly speaking a kind of a
manner which could be regarded if not as
universal somewhat
standardized so i suppose that at least
lays a pathway between us
in the uh abyss within which the senses
operate
the the there is the possibility for
real communion that we can look at one
another
and think oh my god that person is hurt
or that person is angry that we can
recognize that
but you know the this you know our man
gladwell wrote that book didn't about we
can all misread it even something that's
regarded as universal
standalone standardized such as facial
expressions there's variety culturally
within those things and
you know my sort of belief as a kind of
i don't know essentialist is that when
we have souls we're coming from a place
of union and
for even to make such a claim even in a
a a
vague whimsical way suggests that there
is a
a means for us to connect to one another
and again ben i sort of i understand
that you feel sort of
agitated by the kind of what you regard
as a kind of a
concoction around identity identitarian
matters and i i i
recognize what you were saying i
recognize it
but i i feel a with that the kind of
clarity of thought that you offer the
ability to communicate
that you have that i suppose you need to
echo or to repeat simply something i
said earlier is like that when you talk
about you know corruption the
relationship between government
and corporations the hypocrisy the
hollowness and emptiness of the emphatic
nature of much of that communication
i find myself i i mean i i agree with
you
and i've i feel
that where possible we or
yield and be compassion yield and be
compassionate wherever possible i don't
like even
i'm not just talking about sort of
identity stuff i'm talking about like
you know
man guns where do i stand on guns i know
that when i lived in america i kind of
thought oh wow
man i could have a gun that sort of
seems amazing
to me i know i went to a gun range but
it was like kind of the idea
it sort of troubled me it troubles me to
think of the availability of
numerous weapons but cool when i chat to
joe
rogan i'm a vegan i couldn't kill or
hurt an animal it doesn't seem right to
me
i'm not by the way sort of some listless
crystal worshipping mystic
i believe in power and standing up for
what you believe in
situations may present themselves that
require a
kind of you know some serious sacrifice
sacrifice um but
again i try not to let my
attention dwell too heavily on matters
that
seem almost like they're constructed to
become a kind of
this is sort of a cyclone of impor of
impossibility that can't present
conclusions
only confusion if people say that you
know like
look i don't know what it's like to be
anybody else but me
i remember when our daughter was given
to us and the midwife said she her
senses are not yet evolved she's in
darkness and
i considered that even as the senses
come online
and come together the curated and minute
aspect of reality that we can appreciate
is
so limited and and isn't part of your
own religious belief the idea that there
are dimensions
consciousness realms that are
inaccessible due to the
limitations of our ability to hold
knowledge limitations of our instruments
you know even if we amplify those
instruments till we can see or at least
sense dark matter
even if in the subparticular world we
can see the rules of
newtonian physics falling apart
chuckling at our innocence
you know if this is the physical world
then
i'm not going to i don't want to condemn
people
for a kind of cultural discourse that i
i don't feel like a solution
i don't think a solution lies in that
direction what i feel like is
we must be vigorously and
vitally loving this is why i feel like
and oh how are you going to apply that
how
how's that as a policy how are you going
to run that out in a library darling
you know like but what i feel mate
is that you know if people want to live
away okay you live that way
you know how if we're not talking about
300 million population if we're talking
about
you know like the apes we are 150
population 150 people
you you know maybe in broader
confederacy real
devolution the ability if okay if that's
how you feel you
feel that you want to educate children
that way okay okay
we educate children this way okay like
the
minute like in like the tribes that are
not yet
modernized they're not going to be
there will be an acceptance that there
are cultural differences that there are
cultural differences and i think in
america now with the ubiquity and
immediacy of this kind of communication
i think we get ourselves hopelessly
entangled
in matters that are very very important
to individuals that are
expressing them clearly but for a
culture i think that
our focus has got to be on finding
things that we can agree on and finding
ways of tackling the
real issues of power the ability to
control
cultural outcomes i just simply don't
feel when they say 20 years ago when the
whole debate was
much more focused on islamists and
extremism and terrorism like who doesn't
abort and condemn
violent acts who doesn't but i felt like
where is the real power where is the
real power where is the real power i.e
the ability to
organize who's got resources who goes
where who gets to do what that's
you know i don't want to be distracted
too much in this semantic
trivia even though it has great weight
and importance for some people me as a
person outside of it
i want to be focused in the areas that
seem real to me and like talking about
you know you mentioned mate
you know someone was kind enough to
awaken me from like
drugs and alcohol and show me what it
was that i really wanted and then a
group continued to support me and i
continue to
struggle in permutations of those same
issues even now just like you know sort
of
wanting to feel powerful or important or
whatever it is you know
and but and part of my obligation was
you go and help other people go and help
other people
like it like basic first century
christian ideas feed serve
the poor feed serve the poor and like
all the time that i'm
distracted by my cool little cardigan or
this little necklace or my own
narcissism or how important i might be
or whether i'm getting older and which
of course plainly i am
you know like this is a waste of time
this is a waste of time
and yeah like look you and i we've got
these businesses where we're online
we've got to get views we've got like
you know you have to
make an impact but i feel that part of
that journey
surely should be sort of presenting with
people with some some hope and some
optimism and some love and being men of
god and being men of god does mean being
men of compassion and that does mean
well although i'm not like you and you
are
clearly clearly different from me i'm
going to come at this
from a place of love you know and if the
fist hits the face
you can learn the jujitsu so
russell i want to ask you a few final
questions starting with
can a society survive without any sort
of impending existential threat for it
to fight against and to oppose
but if you would like to hear russell
and me discuss this you'll have to be a
daily wire member go to dailywire.com
click
join you can hear the rest of our
conversation there everybody make sure
to check out both of russell's podcasts
under the skin and above the noise his
youtube channel and also his new audible
original
revelation russell thanks so much for
joining the show it's great to talk to
you
wow man you do a good job of this thanks
[Music]
the ben shapiro show sunday special is
produced by mathis glover
executive producer jeremy boring our
technical director is austin stevens and
our assistant director is pavel wydowsky
our guests are booked by caitlin maynard
editing is by jim nicholl
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina
title graphics are by cynthia angulo the
ben shapiro show sunday special is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021
you